Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Hello tout le monde, ça fait quelques semaines, quelques mois même que je tease cet épisode sur les réseaux sociaux.
On a mis un peu de temps à se caler une date, mais ça c'est fait. Cette semaine, je reçois Alice Coffin. On a par exemple pu discuter ensemble de journalisme, de la question de la neutralité, de ses nombreux combats et de lesbianisme politique.
Alice était de passage à Bruxelles et on s'est invités chez l'amie Myriam Leroy pour faire l'interview. Myriam que je ne remercierai jamais assez d'ailleurs pour tout ce qu'elle a pu faire pour ce podcast.
Détail important avant de se lancer dans l'interview, on parle beaucoup de lesbianisme dans le podcast. J'imagine que pour bon nombre d'entre vous, être lesbienne, ça signifie être une femme et avoir des relations avec d'autres femmes.
Je pense que pour vraiment comprendre le propos d'Alice Coffin, il faut bien dissocier le lesbianisme politique qui est un choix, une conviction personnelle, et la question de l'orientation sexuelle qui n'en est pas un.
Sans plus attendre, Septante Minutes Avec Alice Coffin. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Alice Coffin. Salut Alice.
Salut.
Alice, tu sièges au conseil de Paris au sein de la majorité pour le parti Europe Écologie Les Verts. Tu es cofondatrice de l'EuroCentralAsian Lesbian Community.
Tu es cofondatrice également de l'Association des journalistes LGBT. Auparavant, dans une ancienne vie, tu étais journaliste média pour 20 Minutes.
Et dans une ancienne vie, tu enseignais le journalisme à l'Institut catholique de Paris. Et je pense avoir compris que tu es lesbienne.
Est-ce qu'on peut dire à ce stade que tu es la lesbienne la plus connue de France ou est-ce que c'est trop prématuré ?
Ce qui est compliqué, c'est qu'il y ait pas tant de noms qui surgissent à ce moment-là. C'est ça et c'est ça que raconte un peu, entre autres, Le Génie lesbien, c'est la,
la pénurie, non pas de lesbiennes en France, mais de lesbiennes effectivement qui accèdent à la parole publique, qui accèdent à l'espace médiatique.
Et ça, c'est vrai qu'y en a pas beaucoup.
Alors, on peut parler de, 'fin c'est tout le croisement que tu parviens à faire dans le livre, c'est à la fois
la question de l'invisibilisation des lesbiennes de manière générale et la façon dont les médias, en particulier en France, on va y revenir,
sont particulièrement complices de ces questions-là.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu as eu l'occasion de confirmer ? Donc ton livre Le Génie lesbien, sorti y a presque un an, le 30 septembre 2020.
Est-ce que lors de ton press tour, toutes les chaînes radio, télé, rédaction de presse pour ton livre, est-ce que tu as eu l'occasion de confirmer tout ce que tu écris dans le livre ?
Absolument. Même plus que ça. C'est-à-dire que toute l'analyse qui est faite du système médiatique
dans le livre, elle s'est parfaitement illustrée, et hélas, au-delà, hein, vraiment encore de ce que je pouvais imaginer dans la façon dont les journalistes ont reçu
Le Génie lesbien.
C'est-à-dire que en gros, y avait plusieurs attitudes. Le livre, d'une manière générale, il a très très très largement trouvé son public, là il a été tiré à vingt-cinq mille.
Enfin, ça, c'est pas le problème du lectorat, c'est le problème vraiment de qu'est-ce qu'y a comme obstacle pour une parole lesbienne, mais de manière générale féministe, minoritaire en France.
Et comment y a systématiquement des obstacles qui se dressent lorsqu'on veut porter cette parole-là. Alors, ça s'est illustré de différentes manières.
Auparavant, le principal obstacle, finalement, c'est le silence, l'indifférence, comme si les lesbiennes n'existaient pas.
C'est ce qu'on a pu voir en France, par exemple, au moment des discussions sur la PMA qui ont duré des années et des années et pendant lesquelles, alors qu'on discutait de leur sort,
dans les journaux, et cetera, les lesbiennes n'étaient pas invitées autour de la table, soit pendant les débats médiatiques et discuter de PMA, parfois uniquement entre hommes ou en tout cas très rarement avec des lesbiennes.
Donc c'est comme si elles n'existaient pas. Ça, c'était, moi, je trouvais l'invisibilisation une des, un des principaux mécanismes de la lesbophobie.
Pour le livre, ils ont eu un peu plus de mal, mais parce que moi, j'avais un statut aussi, déjà un peu d'être présente dans la sphère publique.
J'étais, je suis élue au Conseil de Paris. Y avait eu un petit focus médiatique sur moi avant la sortie du livre à l'été 2020 pour des actions que j'avais menées en politique.
Donc, ils pouvaient pas faire tout à fait semblant que ça n'existait pas. Donc là, c'est l'autre forme de, bah de discrimination médiatique, c'est le fait de s'autoriser à absolument déformer une parole-
Ouais, ouais
...à complètement la,
avec beaucoup de malhonnêteté, de mauvaise foi. Mais ce qui est intéressant, ça peut arriver dans d'autres cas, hein, je veux dire, mais je pense qu'y a quelque chose de très très spécifique quand ça s'applique à des minorités.
Et là, aux lesbiennes en l'occurrence. Moi, j'ai vu des articles, mais enfin vraiment incroyables dans la presse qui réellement, c'est pas juste tronquer les citations, mais réellement les déformer.
Ça allait de Paris Match aux ondes des radios, et cetera. Ils faisaient des articles, mais pour le déformer, parce que je pense que là, ils pouvaient plus l'ignorer.
Donc il fallait quand même œuvrer à ce que cette parole finalement considérée comme dangereuse, menaçante, ne puisse pas avoir trop d'écho dans la sphère publique.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est pourquoi c'est possible. Pourquoi un tel degré, en fait, de déformation qui a vraiment été extrêmement, extrêmement violent, hein.
Pourquoi c'est possible dans le cas d'une parole minoritaire et pas dans d'autres ? Je crois que c'est parce que, précisément,
sur les lesbiennes, y a pas beaucoup de choses en fait, dans les médias ou dans les cours, dans les cours-
Mmh
...d'université. Et c'est pareil pour d'autres minorités en France. C'est-à-dire que on peut s'autoriser à raconter n'importe quoi sur une catégorie de la population lorsque précisément cette catégorie-là, elle n'est pas
source cible d'enquêtes, de reportages.
Donc y a pas d'information suffisamment fiable et ce qui ouvre en fait le champ au grand n'importe quoi. C'est pour ça que moi d'ailleurs, j'ai constaté que très souvent, tout ce qu'on nomme des fake news, de la désinformation,
c'est pas tellement anodin que ça soit très souvent lié à des sujets qui concernent des minorités.
Par exemple en France, énormément les musulmans et les musulmanes. On va avoir des fake news d'un degré complètement inouï où ça va partir en live sur
un homme politique comme, qui s'appelle Jean-François Copé, mais peu importe son nom parce que ça mérite pas de rester dans l'histoire, mais qui raconte,
que les petits Blancs se font voler leur pain au chocolat, etc.
Enfin, c'est n'importe quoi, c'est du fake news complet. Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que c'est pas du tout anodin-
Mmm-hmm
...que ça s'applique à des pans de la population qui par ailleurs ne font pas l'objet de récits-
N'ont pas voix au chapitre
...de reportages, n'ont pas voix au chapitre et ne peuvent pas elles-mêmes réaffirmer, bah leur vécu.
Ouais et dans le cas des musulmans, des musulmanes, c'est particulièrement évident puisque on parle chaque année en France
de la question du port du foulard, mais rarement sont invitées sur les plateaux les femmes musulmanes.
Jamais pratiquement. Y a eu des enquêtes qui ont été faites. On avait ciblé des enquêtes médiatiques qui montraient, j'crois que c'était à l'automne 2019, où y avait eu, j'crois c'était 180 et quelques
plateaux qui parlaient du voile et y en avait pas-
Mmm-hmm
...enfin le voile n'était pas là.
Et donc y a ce phénomène d'invisibilisation des minorités. Et puis finalement, quand on se retrouve quand même dans une situation où on finit par avoir Alice Coffin en plateau par exemple, chez Europe 1, donc chez Bolloré,
là on se lance dans une opération où on déforme complètement les propos et on diabolise les lesbiennes de manière générale, le lesbianisme politique.
Vouloir gommer symboliquement la moitié de l'humanité, n'est-ce pas là la définition d'un projet génocidaire moral ? Atterré par cette approche binaire excluante et revancharde qui abîme des années de révolution subtile.
Détester les hommes, ce n'est pas excessif quand même un peu ?
Alice Coffin, quand elle dit que la solution, c'est éliminer les hommes du paysage, etc.
C'est la guerre.
Oui, mais c'est une forme d'apartheid, si vous voulez-
Oui
...qu'elle réclame.
Oui, oui, oui, oui.
Un dessin dans le Canard enchaîné vous compare aux intégristes, aux islamistes qui ont le même discours contre les femmes.
Mais quelle différence entre vous les intégristes ? Elle a également écrit, je cite : « Il faut éliminer les hommes ». Vous avouerez qu'il y a de quoi sursauter.
Ne pas admettre l'altérité, est-ce que ce n'est pas une forme absolue d'obscurantisme ? Alors ça, c'est encore une autre forme, c'est-à-dire que y a une disqualification, une délégitimation de la parole.
C'est-à-dire qu'à aucun moment en fait, on ne va m'octroyer la possibilité, moi, de porter un discours par exemple d'analyse des médias ou d'historique sur une situation en dehors de ma position de lesbienne.
C'est-à-dire que réellement, c'est vu à l'aune de ce que je peux représenter, en termes, pff, dans leurs yeux sans doute, de sexualité ou je sais pas exactement, mais c'est, c'est...
La parole est disqualifiée en tout cas, c'est jamais, vous avez beau faire, ce qui a été le cas pour ce livre, des années d'enquête, des dizaines et des dizaines d'interviews,
ça va passer au prisme de la, une rhétorique lesbophobe extrêmement ancienne.
Moi, j'étais très surprise en fait par la présence, la permanence de cette rhétorique-là lesbophobe qui en gros revient à, les lesbiennes veulent éliminer tous les hommes quoi.
C'est vraiment un « ah » et elles détestent les mecs et c'est vraiment une ritournelle. Et ça, tous les propos vont être analysés à cette aune-là.
De même, mais c'est valable aussi pour la parole féministe hein, comme c'est valable pour d'autres paroles. Moi, je cumule un peu parce que je suis aussi, je
siège aussi avec le Parti écologiste et c'est très valable pour la parole écologiste aussi.
C'est-à-dire qu'y a vraiment un mur en fait médiatique là-dessus, un mur journalistique qui fait qu'on ne peut pas même énoncer des,
des vérités ou extrêmement factuelles hein, finalement, et qui sont sans cesse, on l'a vu sur l'écologie, sur le climatoscepticisme, etc.
Bon bah c'est pareil dans un champ féministe, dans un champ lesbien. Vous, vous ne pouvez même pas arriver en fait, mais c'est tout l'objet en fait de la fin du livre, c'est-à-dire que
on sait plus ce qu'il faut à la fin parce que les chiffres sont là, sont écrasants, sont terribles sur la domination masculine et ses conséquences.
Et pourtant tout ça, bah ça suffit pas. C'est autre chose qui se joue, bah qui est extrêmement structurel.
Et c'est bien ça qui est très, très très compliqué à déminer en fait.
Mmm. Et donc pour les médias, il y a, en particulier en France, ce culte d'un certain modèle de la neutralité, l'objectivité.
On incarne le neutre, le factuel et un regard autre, situé serait disqualifié automatiquement. C'est le cas aussi, je pense, dans le domaine académique en France.
On avait reçu Julie Dachez qui faisait son doctorat sur l'autisme, qui est elle-même militante autiste.
Mmm.
Et non, on ne peut pas faire un doctorat sur le sujet. Vous êtes directement concernée, ça vous disqualifie immédiatement, etc.
Absolument. C'est, et moi, c'est vraiment ce que j'ai expérimenté, quand j'étais à la rédaction de 20 Minutes, c'est-à-dire que on m'interdisait quoi vraiment d'écrire des articles qui avaient trait à,
dans leur langage, ils appelaient ça l'homosexualité,
les droits des femmes,
parce que j'étais féministe et lesbienne.
Et donc il y avait à leurs yeux une neutralité, une objectivité journalistique nécessaire pour traiter les sujets qui me, bah qui me disqualifiaient.
Moi, tout l'objet du livre, c'est aussi de démonter cette notion-là de neutralité, évidemment dans le champ médiatique, mais bien au-delà hein.
Je pense qu'effectivement ça vaut dans le champ universitaire, ça vaut dans le champ politique, ça vaut dans différents champs.
Je pense que c'est pas nouveau. C'est-à-dire que pourtant c'est pas un déminage nouveau. Ça figure dans l'introduction du Deuxième sexe, de Simone de Beauvoir.
Dès les premières pages, elle dit : « En fait, le neutre, c'est l'homme ». Et puis la femme, c'est l'autre, tout-
Mmh
...c'est l'autre donc-
Et encore dans les discours d'Emmanuel Macron-
Voilà exactement. On retrouve ça et c'est pas facile parce que, en tout cas dans le champ médiatique, c'est particulièrement pas facile parce que ça semble
aller de soi, même dans une espèce de vulgate ou d'opinion majoritaire sur le journalisme, de dire : « Bah oui bien sûr, les journalistes ils doivent être objectifs.
» Ça quand même, c'est la moindre des choses, c'est le b.a.-ba. Moi c'est ce qu'on m'a enseigné en école de journalisme comme si l'objectivité allait de soi
dans le regard qu'on peut avoir sur la, sur la-- et même de bonne foi hein chez certaines personnes.
Alors que précisément, moi j'estime que cette objectivité-là, elle ne reflète que la subjectivité des dominants en fait.
Elle est la subjectivité de certains et absolument pas une objectivité. Pour le dire un peu plus simplement, bah y a des personnes en fait dans la population qui ont le droit d' parler absolument de tout
sans qu'on pense qu'ils parlent au nom de leur vécu.
En gros si vous êtes un homme blanc hétéro, personne va venir vous demander des comptes en vous disant : « Bah quand même, est-ce que t'es pas un petit peu influencé par ton hétérosexualité quand tu nous dis ça ?
» Non, on va pas présenter les choses comme ça. Alors que pour le reste de la population, tout propos est soumis à suspicion, en particulier dans le journalisme.
Ça, c'est la première chose, c'est que d'une part cette objectivité, pour moi, ça n'existe pas. Et la deuxième chose qui est encore plus compliquée à renverser, par rapport à des,
des préjugés, c'est de dire non seulement elle existe pas et ça n'est pas grave en plus.
C'est même tout à fait intéressant d'assumer un certain vécu, un certain regard, un certain point de vue lorsqu'on est journaliste pour faire correctement son métier.
Et moi le fait d'être lesbienne, le fait d'être militante, le fait d'être féministe est je pense ce qui m'a le plus aidée à faire correctement du journalisme.
Mmh.
Vraiment.
Et dans le livre tu fais la comparaison avec la situation aux États-Unis où tu as l'occasion de-
Mmh mmh
...de faire enquête pendant six mois,
et tu expliques que là-bas justement c'est tout le contraire, on dit : « Bah pour couvrir l'actualité des communautés afro-américaines, mais c'est évident qu'il faut quelqu'un de directement concerné qui va pouvoir
se connecter avec les sources, aller sur le terrain, etc.
» En France, c'est tout l'inverse. Et une explication que tu fournis dans le livre, une explication marxiste, c'est de dire : « C'est un tour de passe-passe économique.
Si vous affirmez que l'objectivité est possible, alors vous justifiez la disparition de milliers de titres puisqu'il n'y a qu'une vérité, celle de l'objectivité, alors plus besoin de diversité.
» Mais justement j'étais surpris de lire ça puisque, bah si on cherche une logique néolibérale ultra capitaliste qui cherche à diminuer le nombre de personnes qui peuvent avoir voix au chapitre,
on irait peut-être plutôt les chercher là où le racisme systémique est,
est-- je sais pas s'il est encore plus présent, mais il est très présent aux États-Unis.
Et justement non, c'est aux États-Unis que on a un regard sur le journalisme qui est tout à fait contraire.
Donc là j'étais surpris. Pourquoi est-ce que c'est le cas comme ça en France, mais pas aux États-Unis ?
Alors je pense que-- 'fin je veux me garder aussi de généralités parce que il peut y a-- mais c'est vrai que je-- bah je pense qu'il y a une réflexion
plus profonde sur la presse, mais qui est liée beaucoup,
euh-- alors qui est liée à des facteurs culturels, qui est liée à la taille du pays aussi qui permet qu'en fait quand vous avez un bassin de population bien plus grand
aux États-Unis qu'en France, ça veut dire que par exemple une presse dite communautaire, une presse qui va toucher par exemple les lesbiennes,
les noirs, elle va avoir un bassin de population, d'électorat bien plus important.
Elle va pouvoir être viable économiquement. Alors que en France, bah évidemment y aura bien moins de personnes
qui vont être touchées donc c'est plus compliqué économiquement de mettre en place des systèmes de presse communautaire même si je--
encore une fois y a d'autres facteurs, mais sur un simple pan économique,
la taille évidemment de la population joue énormément là-dessus sur la possibilité ou pas de développer une presse communautaire qui est une presse absolument essentielle hein.
C'est parce que c'est vraiment par là qu'on va sortir certains sujets, qu'on va pouvoir les approfondir et qui est perçu, alors là c'est une deuxième raison en France, comme une abomination.
De toute façon le mot « communautaire » en France est perçu comme une abomination, mais alors une presse communautaire je pense que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est vécu de manière extrêmement compliquée pourtant-
On y viendra, on y viendra.
Voilà c'est-- et pourtant c'est précisément ce qui a manqué, d'avoir une presse communautaire forte pendant les discussions sur le mariage pour tous.
C'est ce qui manque vraiment parce qu'on peut comprendre que les médias généralistes, si ça leur arrive de pointer leur focale sur telle ou telle question qui concerne plus,
par exemple les lesbiennes, on peut aussi comprendre que ça va pas être à longueur de page et c'est bien pour ça qu'il y a besoin d'une presse qu'on pourrait appeler une presse spécialisée.
Oui. Donc ici on parle spécifiquement de la France. Bon après en toute honnêteté ça s'applique également à la Belgique francophone en tout cas ça déborde un petit peu.
Quand justement tu as fait ton press tour, j'ai cru remarquer que justement ce chapitre sur la neutralité et les problèmes concernant le journalisme en francophonie du coup, en France, était relativement peu abordé.
Qu'est-ce que-- c'était quoi la réception de ce chapitre d'après toi ?
Oui, mais non, non, c'était vraiment, ils en parlaient pas. Ça n'existait pas.
C'était quand même intéressant parce que les-- principalement c'était tout de même
ce qui les intéressait beaucoup, c'est de savoir que mon Dieu, mes livres ne vont plus
être lus quand c'était des journalistes hommes puisqu'ils ont beaucoup focalisé sur une phrase qui disait que j'essayais justement précisément de ne plus,
plus lire de livres d'hommes ou du moins de privilégier les ouvrages d'autres que ceux que j'avais déjà lus pendant 25 ans quoi, pendant ma scolarité et mes études.
Et non, le chapitre sur les médias, c'est vrai qu'ils posaient pas beaucoup de questions là-dessus. Alors après, des podcasts particuliers, des journalistes bien sûr, y a eu des personnes qui ont super bien fait leur boulot.
Mais sinon, ça c'est pas du tout étonnant parce que-- donc moi j'essayais d'exercer
quand j'étais journaliste à temps plein l'activité de journaliste média
qui est pour moi une spécialité du journalisme absolument primordiale et qui est extrêmement peu développée dans les rédactions françaises, beaucoup plus aux États-Unis aussi là encore.
Les journalistes médias, c'est comme bon, les journalistes économiques traitent d'économie, les journalistes sportifs de sport, journalistes culturels de culture et puis les journalistes médias s'occupent des médias en fait.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils font ce boulot-là d'enquête, de reportage sur les autres journalistes. Et ça, c'est extrêmement faible comme domaine.
Y a des réda-- la plupart des rédactions n'en ont pas ou très très peu-
Ça présume qu'on peut remettre en question le travail de journaliste.
C'est intéressant parce que ça, j'en parle-- j'essaye vraiment de comprendre. Et les arguments donnés sont parfois : « Oui, mais non, ça n'intéresse personne, c'est de l'entre-soi, on va pas parler de nous-mêmes ».
Y a une gêne parfois vraiment chez les journalistes à faire ça. Y a des réflexes évidemment corporatistes aussi, qui visent à se protéger.
Et puis y a quand même aussi, je crois, des craintes de
bloquer un peu sa carrière. Enfin, très clairement, moi j'ai-- y a des endroits où j'ai pas été invitée aussi parce que quand vous enquêtez sur d'autres journalistes ou et cetera, bon, ils sont pas forcément disposés ensuite à
vous ouvrir leur micro ou à vous recruter dans leur rédaction.
Donc c'est pas une spécialité très simple.
Ouais.
Si maintenant, je prends ma baguette magique et je décide que Sandrine Rousseau remporte les élections présidentielles l'an prochain et que tu es nommée à la tête du ministère de la Culture, du CSA et de tout ça,
et que tu peux faire le ménage comme ça t'intéresse, comment est-ce qu'on résout ces questions ?
Comment est-ce qu'en tout cas, on lance un mouvement de réflexion par rapport à ces questions puisque à part toi, je n'entends pas beaucoup remettre tout ça en question.
En fait, j'pense qu'il faut profondément modifier l'enseignement du journalisme et sa pratique et la façon dont on le discute.
Parce que ce dont je parle, c'est pas moi dans Le génie lesbien, je l'ai transmis comme ça, mais c'est pas moi qui l'ai inventé.
C'est pareil pour l'histoire des lesbiennes, c'est un ouvrage très collectif et qui s'appuie évidemment sur un ensemble d'études qui ont déjà été faites.
Et ce que j'explique sur les médias, sur les questions de la neutralité, même si je le conceptualise d'une certaine manière qui est la mienne, c'est le B.A.BA des media studies qui ont été développés
au Royaume-Uni, notamment par l'école de Birmingham ou dans d'autres cas.
Et les media studies qui sont les études de médias racontent tout ça très bien. Et ce qui me sidère, c'est qu'on n'en entend pas un mot pendant nos études de journalisme.
C'est-à-dire que ça n'existe pas cette réflexion-là, ça n'existe pas. Donc c'est extrêmement, extrêmement problématique.
Donc déjà, je pense qu'il y a vraiment toute une refonte à faire de la façon dont le journalisme s'enseigne.
Et après, on sait que le journalisme, ça peut aussi-- on n'est pas obligé de passer par des écoles ou des universités. Parfois, ça peut aussi s'apprendre directement dans les rédactions, mais également dans les rédactions.
C'est pas possible, en fait, qu'il y ait jamais ou quasi pas de réflexion plus globale sur l'exercice du métier et ça n'intervient pas.
C'est-à-dire que c'est réellement ce qui peut intervenir et c'est important aussi. C'est respecter certains fondamentaux avec lesquels je suis tout à fait, avec lesquels je suis tout à fait d'accord, c'est-à-dire
essayer d'avoir le plus de sources possibles pour un article, essayer de l'écrire lisiblement, tout ça.
Pour moi, c'est ça le B.A.BA du métier, les fondamentaux, c'est pas les questions de neutralité ou d'objectivité. Mais sur la question de quelle réception,
comment on fait pour bien comprendre en fait, y compris dans je pense le média,
en tout cas en termes de-- qui est important en France et que je respecte le plus, mais qui pourtant a ce problème-là aussi.
Je vous donne un exemple, celui de Mediapart. Pour moi, y a quelque chose qui m'a choquée et qui pour moi reflète une absence.
Et pourtant, vraiment, j'admire beaucoup leur travail. Je pense qu'il y a une réflexion, mais vraiment pas du tout assez poussée.
Mediapart a fait des enquêtes récemment et ils ont bien eu raison de le faire sur les questions de harcèlement moral, de certains, et en l'occurrence certaines parlementaires sur leurs collaborateurs et collaboratrices.
Extrêmement important, sujet absolument majeur. Seulement, les deux grandes enquêtes qu'ils ont fournies, c'était une enquête sur Laëtitia Avia, qui était une élue noire, femme noire, et une enquête sur Esther Benbassa, qui était une
sénatrice aussi racisée.
Entendons-nous, c'est extrêmement important. Je ne dis pas qu'ils ne devaient pas faire ces enquêtes, Mediapart. C'était primordial qu'ils les fassent.
Et moi, j'apporte mon soutien entier aux collaborateurs, aux collaboratrices. C'est pas ça le problème. C'est de ne pas avoir pensé les logiques du journalisme et de ne publier,
de faire un effet en fait de focus et de ne pas avoir publié ces enquêtes-là avec cinq, six, sept autres enquêtes parce qu'on sait à quel point
c'est un sport pratiquement, 'fin vraiment assez national, le harcèlement de collaborateurs et collaboratrices dans les sphères parlementaires.
Alors comment ça se fait ? Comment ça se fait ? Si c'est aussi répandu, pourquoi est-ce qu'on se retrouve avec les deux enquêtes qui portent sur des femmes racisées ?
Bah y a des explications là-dessus. Y a des explications qui sont que ce sont des terrains sur lesquels c'est un peu plus simple de mener des enquêtes sur les femmes de manière générale parce que finalement, les gens ont moins peur de témoigner.
Y a plus de possibilités de témoignages, ça fait moins peur que d'aller témoigner que quand votre supérieur est un homme qui va avoir plus de pouvoir et encore plus si c'est un homme blanc.
Donc c'est aussi plus facile d'aller témoigner contre des femmes racisées. Et je crois que ne pas prendre ce problème-là, ne pas avoir ça en tête, ne pas voir les mécanismes de comment on construit une enquête journalistique,
c'est ne pas réfléchir assez aux problématiques de réception, les problématiques d'enquête, tout ce qui entoure en fait l'exercice du journalisme.
Et encore une fois, quel est l'effet, quel effet de sens ça produit ? Et comment dans ce cas-là, bah il vaut mieux attendre un peu et puis dire : « Bah on va sortir en même temps ».
Et y aura évidemment Laëtitia Avia et Esther Benbassa qui ont été des enquêtes très importantes à réaliser, mais elles sortent avec sept ou huit autres enquêtes.
Et là, on évite cet effet-là qui est une déformation du réel, finalement, qui est une déformation du réel par
un biais du travail journalistique qu'on peut comprendre parce que ouais, ça va être plus-- et y a plein d'autres explications aussi qui font que oui, dans ces cas-là, ça a été plus facile d'enquêter.
Et j'ai pris exprès l'exemple de Mediapart qui est vraiment par ailleurs l'exemple, donc j'espère qu'ils m'en voudront pas, mais parce que imaginez si à Mediapart c'est comme ça.
C'est évidemment encore plus dramatique ailleurs parce que c'est vraiment ceux qui pratiquent, je crois, parmi ceux qui pratiquent avec le plus de soucis de ce qu'ils peuvent produire en termes d'effet de sens d'information.
Mais ça, c'est une manière de-- au-delà, pour comprendre ça, je pense qu'il faut sortir de l'idée que l'information, elle existe en tant que telle, que c'est un réel.
Ce n'est pas du tout vrai. L'information, c'est un récit, c'est un choix d'aller prendre une toute petite partie du réel qui se déroule sous nos yeux au quotidien et de dire : « Toi, tu vas devenir une information.
Toi, je te prends là, toi, pan de réalité, et je t'amène aux yeux du public et je te labellise information ». Et ça, ça s'appelle un choix éditorial.
Et ça, ça dépend d'énormément de conditions qui sont : où est-ce qu'on peut se rendre ? Qu'est-ce qu'on voit ?
Quel argent on a pour le faire ? Quel choix on fait ? Tout ça peut très bien se justifier, mais n'allons pas prétendre que c'est la réalité en fait qui nous renvoie à ça.
J'ai eu récemment un affrontement un peu sévère à ce sujet
parce que je critiquais, c'était la primaire écologiste et je critiquais les choix opérés par Radio France de consacrer pratiquement un quart du débat de la primaire écologique à des questions de laïcité et d'insécurité.
Et alors les-- vous parliez de Sonia Mabrouk tout à l'heure ou Repain ou d'autres journalistes
et des harceleurs, je l'appelle harceleur comme Raphaël Enthoven, je l'appelle volontairement harceleur parce qu'on,
on multiplie et qu'on cite des centaines de fois le nom d'une même femme comme Rokhaya Diallo, Laure Dernin, bah ça s'appelle harceler quelqu'un.
Faut l'appeler par ce nom-là. M'ont reproché, m'ont dit : « Ah bah bien sûr, ça n'existe pas. Alors vraiment, vous ne voyez rien, vous ne voyez pas l'insécurité, vous ne voyez pas le réel, c'est les journalistes qui inventent ».
Il s'agit pas de dire ça. Il s'agit de dire qu'est-ce que-- sur quoi vous choisissez de passer autant de temps, sur quoi vous choisissez de braquer la focale.
Ce n'est pas que ça n'existe pas, mais votre récit, il est une version uniquement du réel. Et ça, ça me semble
encore une fois du b.a.-ba à comprendre et à-- on peut discuter après, on peut dire : « Mais oui, mais je choisis de m'occuper de ça », mais ne me dites pas que c'est des chiffres et que c'est du réel.
Parce que si on veut vraiment parler d'insécurité, et ça, c'est des discours très compliqués à avoir, mais,
si on veut parler par exemple d'insécurité, quand on me dit : « Mais alors le terrorisme, et alors-- » Bon bah, les chiffres du terrorisme dans le monde, ça tue 13 000 personnes par an.
L'insécurité climatique, les dérèglements climatiques, c'est 8 millions de personnes par an. Donc ce n'est pas vrai que c'est un truc du,
du réel et pour protéger les gens et que c'est d'être une horrible gauchiste que de ne pas penser...
C'est qu'il y a des choix qui ne privilégient pas nécessairement la sécurité des personnes.
Mh. Ouais, une ligne éditoriale, c'est déjà un exercice de pouvoir.
Bien sûr.
Donc juste pour revenir à la question d'origine, la question donc de quel changement apporter, comment, quels outils fournir à la presse française ?
Donc ouais, l'enseignement en est une partie absolument primordiale, et des choix draconiens en termes d'embauche et de recrutement, en fait, des rédactions.
Plus de journalisme média, plus de remise en question.
Plus de journalisme média, plus de journalistes racisés surtout, vraiment. Mais vraiment, les rédactions-- 'fin y a un passage dans le livre qui s'appelle vraiment, sur les salles terriblement blanches, des rédactions françaises.
Et donc vraiment apporter des profils de manière générale absolument différents dans les rédactions. Et attention, ce n'est pas qu'une question de lutte comme-- ça, c'est valable pour toute entreprise.
Pour toute entreprise, bah, y a un problème si réellement, vous ne recrutez des salariés que d'un seul profil. Ça s'appelle de la-- voilà, c'est la discrimination qui en est à l'origine.
Donc évidemment, il faut le combattre. Très bien.
Mais en journalisme, ça a des conséquences particulièrement graves puisque encore une fois,
je pense que l'objectivité n'existe pas et que la façon dont vous allez raconter le monde et les informations que vous allez choisir dépendent profondément de votre vécu, de l'endroit où vous habitez, des entourages,
de votre couleur de peau y compris, parce que de toute façon, le réel ne va pas réagir à vous de la même manière.
C'était une journaliste qui me racontait ça aux États-Unis,
que évidemment, vous ne ramenez pas les mêmes informations selon que vous êtes journaliste noire ou blanche dans un congrès des républicains aux États-Unis, parce que les personnes ne vont pas réagir de la même manière, donc vous ne--
c'est pas mieux, moins bien, c'est juste que ça sera différent.
Donc il est extrêmement important que toutes les journalistes aux différents profils soient représentés. Parce qu'on n'arrivera jamais à reproduire
l'ensemble du réel dans un même journal, mais on se donne au moins un peu plus de chances de le faire si on a des pères Dieu qui ne proviennent pas
de cerveaux ou de corps éduqués de la même façon, habitant au même endroit, etc.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment absolument, ouais, absolument capital.
Quand on pose ces questions-là de pourquoi y a-t-il autant d'hommes, pourquoi y a-t-il autant de personnes blanches dans les rédactions, la question de,
voilà, dénoncer le fait que l'objectivité en journalisme n'existe pas et casser cette image pourtant très,
très célébrée, voilà, que dans toutes les rédactions.
Quand on se lance dans cette démarche-là, on s'attaque à l'indiscutable, des choses qui sont-- y a une forme de dogmatisme, voilà, un culte pour ces conceptions-là.
Toi, tu arrives à t'y attaquer ?
Mh.
Pourquoi ? Qu'est-ce qui est spécial chez Alice Coffin qui fait qu'elle peut s'attaquer à l'indiscutable ?
Non, mais je pense qu'y a-- c'est un sujet qui commence un peu quand même à émerger, j'espère, mais pas beaucoup, c'est vrai, dans les rédactions françaises.
Je pense, c'est pour ça que je disais : « Lesbienne, ça fait de moi une meilleure journaliste », parce que je pense que ça,
ce constat-là,
il ne m'est pas venu vraiment par une réflexion de journalisme média, il m'est vraiment venu parce que j'étais lesbienne et parce que j'ai été confrontée très directement
à six mois intenses qui ont été les six mois de discussions sur le mariage pour tous en France entre la fin 2012 et le début 2013.
Où chaque jour, dans ma salle de rédaction à 20 Minutes, mais aussi en écoutant la radio, la télé, et cetera,
je voyais en action se déployer cette question de la fausse neutralité et ses ravages en fait, dans le traitement de l'information.
Du coup, je pense que ça me touchait évidemment extrêmement personnellement, et que je voyais bien surtout les conséquences extrêmement toxiques.
Parce que là, ça pourrait n'être qu'une discussion académique, universitaire sur tiens, le journalisme, les questions de neutralité, de l'objectivité.
Non. Ce qui s'est passé dans ce moment-là en France, et c'est à partir de vraiment de ces années-là que moi, je me suis intéressée à cette question beaucoup de la neutralité, de l'objectivité journalistique, c'est qu'en plus,
le fait que les journalistes, justement, n'aient pas souhaité laisser la parole dans les rédactions à des personnes qui étaient bien plus concernées et qui étaient bien plus au courant, donc ils ont raconté absolument n'importe quoi,
mais surtout, ils en ont perdu leur réflexe journalistique qu'ils vont appliquer dans d'autres secteurs, c'est-à-dire de pas en-- en l'occurrence, un journaliste à la base, ça doit pas se laisser
trop impressionner ou trop facilement convaincre par des éléments de communication qui viennent d'une communication d'entreprise, d'une communication politique du gouvernement, et cetera.
Et là, ils ont perdu tout leur réflexe quand il s'est agi de la Manif pour tous qui a déferlé en France parce que la Manif pour tous avait, je pense, moi, un génie de la communication à sa tête qui était Frigide Barjot,
qui n'est pas un génie lesbien, mais qui est un génie absolu de la communication.
Enfin moi, j'ai rencontré et qui est pas du tout quelqu'un de fou ou tout ça, qui est très très brillante en matière de stratégie média.
Soit. Mais et alors ? Votre boulot de journaliste, c'est de contrer ça. Il y a des gens qui sont très forts en com dans d'autres domaines.
Bon bah, il y a des spin doctors en politique. Voilà, il y a des publicitaires. Bon, votre boulot, c'est de le contrer, de pas prendre...
Et là, ils n'étaient pas capables. C'est-à-dire que la Manif pour tous, c'était matin, midi et soir sur les antennes françaises à déverser ces éléments de pure com.
C'était de la com homophobe, mais c'était de la com et de grands grands n'importe quoi qui n'était pas si compliqué, je pense, à déminer journalistiquement, pour peu qu'on s'y intéresse et pour peu qu'on fasse correctement le boulot.
Et du coup, moi, c'est à ce moment-là, parce que
la conséquence, c'est que ça, je pense qu'on s'intéresse et on creuse un sujet qu'en plus, ça vous, voilà, ça vous touche vraiment complètement personnellement, ça touche vos proches, ça touche
vos amoureuses, ça touche...
Donc là, bien entendu, ça vient aussi. C'était une manière en fait de répondre à un traumatisme qui a été vraiment très fort, je pense, chez beaucoup et que
c'était plus simple pour moi à absorber en travaillant aussi sur les causes.
Donc, je me suis tout de suite après vraiment énormément intéressée au traitement médiatique de la Manif pour tous, justement, de qu'est-ce qui s'était passé dans la presse française.
Et en fondant, c'est, la date, elle n'est pas du tout, voilà, anodine. Elle arrive juste un mois après la proclamation du mariage en France, l'association des journalistes
LGBT, elle naît vraiment pendant cette période-là parce qu'on est vraiment nombreux, nombreuses, aussi journalistes gays, lesbiennes, trans dans nos rédactions, à faire ce constat-là quoi, et à vouloir sortir
en voyant que ça a trait au caractère complètement ignorant de nos problématiques, aux questions d'objectivité journalistique, et cetera.
Donc, et je pense que c'est pour ça qu'après, moi, j'ai pu le déployer et l'écrire dans un ouvrage. Mais c'est ce qui est vraiment étonnant, c'est que ça soit pas un champ plus développé, effectivement, en France.
Je vais peut-être revenir sur cette question, mais par un autre angle. Donc on parlait de la question de l'universalisme en France, ce moule dans lequel tout le monde essaie de se fondre.
On parle de, voilà, le grand roman français et pas tellement de singularités, d'exceptions, de différences, voilà, et cetera.
On accepte, on tolère la différence, mais on ne la célèbre pas,
pour dire ça comme ça. Du coup, est-ce que c'est juste de présumer qu'on puisse être attiré, donc être une femme attirée par d'autres femmes, mais en fait ne pas se savoir, ne pas même s'interroger là-dessus ?
Parce que ben non, la norme sociale, c'est : je dois être attiré par quelqu'un de l'autre sexe.
Oui ben moi, c'est ce qui m'est arrivé, au départ. C'est-à-dire que... Et c'est vraiment un bon exemple parce que par ailleurs,
ça peut venir aussi d'une peur ou d'une coercition, d'interdits familiaux qui font que de toute façon-
C'est ça. Exactement
...on va penser à l'exclure, on va même pas aller sur ce chemin-là. Moi, c'était même pas le cas, vraiment. J'ai pas grandi dans un milieu du tout oppressif là-dessus, au contraire.
Bon. Et pourtant, ça m'est même pas venu à l'idée en fait, alors que c'était juste que je n'aurais pas posé les mots de lesbienne parce que ce mot-là, je le connaissais pas, tout simplement.
D'accord.
Il existait pas pour moi. J'avais jamais entendu ce mot-là. J'ai pas entendu ce mot-là avant très longtemps. Et du coup, ben je voyais bien.
Ça me gênait pas du tout d'avoir des sentiments amoureux pour des petites filles ou des filles après, quand j'étais ado, et cetera.
Ça m'embêtait pas. Simplement, j'étais persuadée que ben non, mais un jour, il y aurait le prince charmant. Enfin, c'est, c'est...
Parce que j'avais pas le mot quoi. Et si je regarde en arrière, évidemment, c'était des sentiments amoureux. Et que si on m'avait dit : « Ben non, mais c'est possible.
Et oui, ben ça, il y a bien sûr des couples de femmes, il y a des lesbiennes. » Du coup, je l'aurais traduit complètement différemment.
Et puis j'aurais eu d'autres pans de vie qui se seraient ouverts à moi et qui, là, sont refermés un peu à jamais quoi, parce qu'on revient pas sur une adolescence.
Donc voilà, on revient pas sur une vie en ce qui me concerne, étudiante, pour d'autres une jeunesse. C'est plus possible en fait après.
Et c'est dur parce que c'est vraiment des pans de vie volés là-dessus. Et encore une fois, même pas par— c'est-à-dire c'est vraiment juste, juste, je savais pas quoi.
J'en avais pas vu, y avait pas— et ça, j'espère que ça a bougé. Je vois l'âge de beaucoup d'électrices qui m'écrivent, donc je me dis : « Bon, au moins, elles ont— elles sont jeunes, souvent.
Très très jeunes » et ça, ça me vit bon.
Du coup, qu'est-ce qui fait la différence entre toi, qui as vu, qui as pris conscience de ces choses-là, et les nombreuses autres femmes qui n'ont jamais pris conscience de ça à propos d'elles-mêmes ?
Moi, je pense que c'est vraiment d'avoir eu la chance d'entrer dans la, ou l'envie, je sais pas comment, mais d'être dans la sphère militante, en fait.
Et d'ailleurs, pas spécifiquement, parce que c'est pour ça que je connaissais pas, mais dans la sphère militante féministe qui va se mélanger à certains endroits très fortement à la sphère militante lesbienne aussi.
J'veux dire, y a pas mal de— c'est ce que je raconte aussi dans le livre. Les lesbiennes ont été et sont et seront sans doute très actives dans les combats féministes.
Et c'est ça qui m'a vraiment ouvert les yeux là-dessus. C'est vraiment ce qu'ont permis— moi, j'ai touj— 'fin quand on me demande des conseils, de femmes : « Oui, mais c'est compliqué pour rencontrer.
» Je dis : « Mais va à une réunion militante ». C'est le meilleur endroit que j'ai trouvé pour— vraiment, mes amoureuses, je les ai trouvées là.
Donc vas-y quoi. Et non, je pense c'est vraiment le militantisme féministe qui a permis ça.
À un moment donné, tu fais une citation d'Eric Zemmour dans le livre qui parle de cette idée que le pouvoir est fondamentalement masculin, le pouvoir se confond avec la masculinité.
Et tu expliques que tu n'arrives pas aux mêmes conclusions que lui, mais tu es d'accord avec la prémisse. Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer ?
Oui. Alors c'est très intéressant parce que cette phrase-là, je l'ai réécoutée il y a 48 heures puisque Eric Zemmour était l'invité de Laurent Ruquier et Léa Salamé.
Effectivement, ils t'ont fait tout un segment où—
Et ils ont cité cette phrase.
C'est ça.
Et j'ai envie de dire, Laurent Ruquier, relisez, il m'a invitée pour le livre, pour les gais et les lesbiennes parce qu'en fait, ils allaient pas au bout de l'analyse.
C'est-à-dire que, et c'est ça qui va être compliqué pendant cette campagne présidentielle, c'est que je pense qu'ils sont pas, elles sont pas armés, en fait, pour répondre à Zemmour.
Parce que justement, ils ont recité cette phrase-là en s'en offusquant et en lui disant : « Mais vous vous rendez compte de ce que vous dites ?
Mais c'est pas vrai. Pourquoi vous dites que le pouvoir se dissipe quand il y a des femmes ? » Ils comprennent pas ce qu'il dit.
Parce que moi, je pense qu'il a raison de dire ça au sens, et quand je dis qu'on n'arrive pas aux mêmes conclusions, au sens où le pouvoir politique est intrinsèquement lié à la masculinité.
Le politique lui-même est synonyme de masculin. C'est la même chose en fait. C'est-à-dire que, et ça, là encore, il faut reprendre son historique.
De fait, les femmes ont été exclues du champ politique lorsqu'il a commencé à se formaliser, se conceptualiser, notamment de manière démocratique. Si on prend,
la Troisième République en France qui va produire une installation,
et qui est, au ciment de moi, du groupe collectif féministe auquel j'appartiens, qui s'appelle La Barbe, qui mime justement tous nos grands hommes républicains qui sont censés avoir fondé notre système.
Les femmes en étaient exclues. Les femmes, non seulement n'avaient pas le droit de vote, mais bien évidemment n'étaient pas dans ces cercles-là.
Et tous les codes, en fait, du politique, et je pense même qu'on pourrait pousser bien plus loin.
La politique fait partie des cercles, des boys clubs,
d'un monde qui a été créé spécifiquement pour pouvoir aux hommes, permettre aux hommes de se retrouver entre eux dans une sphère de la masculinité, d'avoir un pouvoir aussi sur les corps des femmes.
Tout ça, évidemment pas que pour ça. Y a aussi certaines figures, voilà, dont je peux être admirative. Mais ça fait aussi—
C'est pensé à la racine, ouais.
C'est aussi à la racine de ça. Donc c'est en cela que je dis que Zemmour a raison. C'est-à-dire que oui, du coup, ça n'est pas prévu, ça n'est pas fait dans les codes.
Si nous restons dans les standards et dans les codes de la politique telle qu'elle a été conçue,
telle que se déroule une campagne présidentielle, telle que se déroulent des réunions politiques, oui, effectivement, quand les femmes arrivent, ça peut plus fonctionner parce que ça ne marche plus de la même manière.
Mais ils ne disent pas autre chose. Les hommes politiques, si vous regardez un peu, moi, j'ai beaucoup lu de la sociologie qui interrogeait des politiques.
Et encore récemment, il y avait un, je sais plus qui c'était, il était connu en plus. Je le retrouve. C'est un homme qui dit : « Depuis que les femmes arrivent en politique, on ne peut plus faire de blagues ».
C'est-à-dire, on ne peut pas mieux définir la façon dont c'étaient des cercles qui étaient vraiment de manière consubstantielle—
De l'autre soir, ouais.
Voilà, faits pour développer une certaine masculinité. Donc de fait, quand les familles arrivent, effectivement, ça s'écroule.
Mais en face, Salamé et Ruquier, je comprends, que ça les choque, la phrase de Zemmour, comme ça, oui. Et moi aussi, elle me— bien sûr que cette pensée-là, elle est—
Elle est en train de misogyner.
Elle est évidemment problématique, évidemment. Mais on ne peut pas en venir à bout sans dire : en fait, c'est l'ensemble du système qu'il faut complètement déverrouiller.
Ça ne marchera pas autrement. C'est-à-dire que les femmes n'ont aucune chance dans ce sys— c'est pour ça que ça ne peut pas fonctionner.
Elles peuvent y arriver à coup d'exceptions, en gros. Elles peuvent, une fois, deux fois, reste— mais en fait, consubstantiellement, elles ne sont pas prévues dans ces codes-là.
Donc ce qu'il faut, et évidemment, c'est ce qui va se passer quand les femmes arriveront en masse, ça changera profondément la définition du pouvoir, la définition du politique et la façon de procéder à—
même là, on commence la campagne présidentielle française, la campagne, et je le vois, puisque moi je soutiens beaucoup Sandrine Rousseau, on en parle très souvent.
C'est-à-dire qu'une campagne— alors le politique, déjà, c'est les codes de la masculinité, mais alors une campagne présidentielle, c'est le summum, en fait, de la—
Du pouvoir
...du pouvoir et de la définition de la virilité. C'est-à-dire que t'es dans la course, dans la compétition, mais complètement des trucs— enfin, c'est complètement idiot.
Je veux dire, la façon dont est prévue l'accession à un pouvoir est absurde, avec des espèces de gens, j'sais pas, qui doivent être comme des surhumains, être capables de tenir pendant des mois, de répondre à...
C'est complètement absurde. C'est une déshumanisation totale ou une masculinisation totale. C'est la même chose, là, à ce niveau-là.
C'est-à-dire qu'on parle plus d'êtres humains ou de— c'est des codes vraiment de compétition extrêmement forcenés et qu'on va retrouver dans d'autres— y a d'autres sphères qui sont réservées.
La politique vraiment incarne ça de manière très forte, mais après, il y a ce qu'on a appelé la caserne et le vestiaire, l'armée, c'était ça aussi, le sport, tout ça.
Ce sont des bastions aussi, et qui sont liés à des notions beaucoup de clans, de groupes. C'est-à-dire que je pense que si on décortique, en fait, moi, c'était un,
un ouvrage suivant que j'avais envie de faire aussi après Le génie lesbien, c'est vraiment,
je parle de la molle farandole dans Le génie lesbien qui décrit vraiment tous ces lieux où on voit les hommes, en fait, un peu dans une tautologie d'être homme, c'est-à-dire qu'ils se tournent entre eux, entre eux, ils sont là, ils sont présents.
Et je crois vraiment que la plupart des secteurs de notre société qui ont été développés sont des secteurs dont la définition est très très très liée à qu'est-ce que la masculinité, qu'est-ce qu'un homme.
Et pour moi, ça vaut autant pour la politique que pour l'art. L'art, c'est pareil, c'est quelque chose qui est en fait— c'est compliqué parce que quand on dit ça, les personnes vont dire : « Mais pas du tout, ça n'a rien à voir ».
Mais si, hélas, moi, je pense que, hélas, tout ça sont— c'est très très profondément des excroissances de la masculinité et que du coup, bah, pour venir à— c'est pour ça que c'est si dur de venir à bout du patriarcat.
Parce qu'en fait, notre société, elle est—
toutes ces manifestations extérieures du monde de l'entreprise, du monde politique, du monde de l'art, du monde du sport, tout a été pensé en fonction de la masculinité telle que définie, entendons-nous.
C'est pas les hommes comme ça. Non. De ce qui a été construit autour de la figure des hommes. Et ça, ça définit énormément des champs, des activités humaines.
Donc ça va être très très long, en fait, de déverrouiller tout ça.
Très long. Mais tu paries sur une femme pour la prochaine présidentielle. Est-ce que c'est pas un pari un peu raté d'avance ?
Alors, mais justement, je pense que... Alors, je parie sur une femme féministe qui a déjà montré son courage puisque Sandrine Rousseau était bien avant MeToo une des élues qui a
contribué à l'émergence de ce qu'on a appelé l'affaire Denis Baupin, donc a dénoncé pour une première fois en France. Et là,
je faisais un petit taquet tout à l'heure, mais grâce notamment à Lénaïg Breteau et à, 'fin, et à l'ensemble du travail absolument remarquable que fait Mediapart sur ces questions-là,
et à Cyril Graziani de France Inter aussi, qui avait co-commené l'enquête.
Y a eu ce moment très important duquel elle était au centre. Donc c'est pas n'importe qui Sandrine Rousseau, quand même, dans sa manière de mener les combats, mais c'est surtout, justement, moi, ce qui m'intéresse, c'est que
elle est tout à fait prête, en fait, à opérer ce renversement-là.
C'est-à-dire qu'on arrive à un point, mais j'y vais parce que je lui fais confiance et je me retrouve complètement dans ses idées écologistes, sociales, etc.
Mais c'est pas seulement ça. C'est que pour moi, la campagne qui s'annonce en France, mais c'est valable, on l'a vu dans d'autres pays, on l'a vu avec Trump, etc.
Y a une zemmourisation très forte de la campagne et y a une extrême droitisation très forte des médias. Je me comprends.
C'est-à-dire, je suis pas du tout en train de dire que le journaliste bascule à l'extrême droite. Mais ce qui se passe quand même depuis quelques années, on le voit avec la montée très forte en puissance
des audiences de CNews, par exemple, en France,
la montée en puissance très forte des audiences de Valeurs actuelles.
Je veux dire, avant, quand on était dans les kiosques à journaux, c'était, j'sais pas, l'Express qui était au fronton, on n'aurait pas vu Valeurs actuelles.
Maintenant, ils sont devant dans les relais H et tout. C'est genre, y a une banalisation, vraiment, des discours.
Et je crois que là, on peut taper sur les journalistes, ça, si on— ça va, je sais faire, on peut dire : « Vraiment, ils font mal leur boulot », tout ça.
Ok. On peut dire : « Qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? » Et en face, c'est vraiment pas solide. Les matinales de France Inter sont aussi, y a une espèce de vraiment...
'Fin moi, j'étais pas invitée, par exemple, pour parler de mon livre. En revanche, ils vont inviter des personnes comme, voilà, Eugénie Bastié ou d'autres, 'fin vraiment des représentants de—
Sur France Inter ?
Ouais, ouais.
Ok, pas invitée, ok. Ça, ça m'étonne.
J'ai été invitée par Nadia Daam dans son émission, mais jamais dans les—
Dans leurs matinales.
Non, mais les matinales radio, absolument pas. Alors que—
Bah sur Europe 1 quand même, mais pas chez France Inter.
Exact. Eh bah, c'est précisément ça. Ce qui se passe, c'est que le seul lieu où on a encore accès en temps de parole de gauche, en fait, et Sandrine Rousseau, elle a été invitée aussi sur Europe 1 d'ailleurs par Mabrouk.
J'en avais discuté avec Sonia Mabrouk d'ailleurs, c'est quand même fou. C'est-à-dire, là, chez Europe 1, ils assument d'avoir Sonia Mabrouk.
Ils assument d'avoir quelqu'un qui journal—
qui, voilà, qui balance toutes ces idées. L'équivalent d'une Sonia Mabrouk, ça voudrait dire que non seulement on serait invité, mais qu'on serait journaliste, Rokhaya Diallo ou moi, sur la matinale de France Inter.
J'ai l'impression que c'est— ou de Radio France. Ça n'est pas près d'arriver. Pourtant, c'est exactement l'équivalent. Donc on n'a pas, en fait, de contre-feu de gauche dans le champ médiatique français.
On n'a pas— ça leur paraîtrait invraisemblable. Alors que je vois pas pourquoi on pourrait pas être les intervieweuses politiques et que je pense qu'on ferait émerger des questions
plus intéressantes que ce que j'entends au micro des matinales de la radio publique française.
Ça, c'est la première chose. Mais moi, ma solution, c'est de me dire : comme ils sont un peu peureux, comme ils sont comme ça, les journalistes,
il va falloir que ça soit les politiques qui fassent le boulot et en fait, que y ait un discours vraiment assumé de gauche, de manière politique, pour changer les lignes journalistiques.
Parce qu'en définitive, ce qui m'intéresse, c'est de changer le récit médiatique. C'est parce que je pense que c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à vraiment peser, enfin à mon niveau, sur les imaginaires.
'Fin voilà, je fais pas de films, je fais pas... Voilà, Céline Sciamma va le faire avec du cinéma, Amandine Gay aussi, mais moi, je fais pas de...
Donc je peux peser. En revanche, je sais faire ça, peser sur un récit médiatique. Et c'est le pari que j'ai fait avec Sandrine Rousseau.
Donc quand on arrive mi-août, en fait, dans la campagne, elle est pas très connue encore, elle est pas, voilà. Donc moi, je— vraiment, on dit : on y va sur les médias.
Et ce qui me fait penser que ça peut fonctionner, c'est précisément la matinale de France Inter animée par Nicolas Demorand et Léa Salamé.
Mmm-hmm.
Pourquoi ? Je la fais brève. Sandrine Rousseau, elle se présente sur le débat, on lui demande : « Pourquoi vous vous présentez ?
» Et elle dit : « Parce que mon humiliation a des limites et parce qu'Emmanuel Macron, alors qu'on avait mené tout ce combat contre les agressions sexuelles en politique, a nommé Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur, alors même,
que des femmes ont dénoncé justement,
son comportement. » Et elle dit ça.
Deux jours plus tard, Gérald Darmanin est invité sur France Inter.
Et là, Nicolas Demorand, il lui dit : « Que pensez-vous de ce que Sandrine Rousseau a déclaré que c'était un scandale, c'était balayer du revers de main le combat de milliers de femmes que de vous avoir nommé ?
» Jamais. Un an plus tôt, il l'avait reçu, il bredouillait quand il a dû prononcer le mot que peut-être, tiens, il était mis en examen.
Il a repris la parole d'un auditeur. Donc Nico— parce qu'il peut s'appuyer sur une vraie parole politique de gauche, il peut le dire au micro de France Inter.
Plutôt que de poser la question directement, il va chercher la citation.
Et donc, ce qui veut dire que si on arrive à faire émerger dans cette campagne présidentielle
une offre politique qui n'existait pas en ce moment, c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'a pas peur de produire une vraie parole féministe, une vraie parole antiraciste, une vraie parole contre les violences policières,
on a peut-être un tout petit espoir d'infléchir le récit médiatique et le comportement journalistique de cette présidentielle.
Et ça, j'en veux pour preuve cet exemple-là où ça a parfaitement fonctionné et je pense qu'on peut le refaire fonctionner énormément de fois.
Seulement, il faut pour ça qu'elle soit candidate et c'est pour ça que moi, je suis assez fâchée, en fait, par exemple, contre les Verts en France qui ne comprennent pas ça.
C'est-à-dire que je ne comprends pas quand on a la chance d'avoir quelqu'un, parce que par ailleurs, elle est quand même de grosse qualité et elle maîtrise vraiment bien ses sujets, d'avoir quelqu'un comme Sandrine Rousseau.
Mais qu'ils s'en aillent, les Yannick Jadot, les Éric Piolle, avec tout le respect que je peux avoir pour eux, mais c'est pas possible qu'ils nous expliquent pas qu'ils sont pour le féminisme.
Vous savez, Éric Piolle, il a dit ça dans son discours, il dit : « Je serai un marchepied pour les féministes, pour les femmes françaises.
» Mais non, mec, t'es pas un marchepied, t'es une porte blindée, là. Bah, allez-vous-en. Et c'est pas, ça veut pas dire— mais venez faire campagne avec nous.
Je veux dire, moi, je serais ravie, voilà, que Éric Piolle, il vienne dans la campagne. Y a pas, c'est pas un souci. Mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne comprennent pas que là, et qu'ils ne le comprennent pas non plus, même électoralement ?
Parce qu'en fait, la dynamique, elle est pas de leur côté. C'est-à-dire, bon, là, je fais de l'analyse politique, mais c'est vraiment— leur offre politique, elle est déjà représentée.
Anne Hidalgo vient d'arriver. C'est la même chose que Jadot. C'est, ils présentent pas quelque chose de nouveau.
Si Sandrine Rousseau, elle est montée en flèche
comme ça aussi, c'est précisément parce qu'il y a toute une partie de la population qui n'est pas représentée dans l'offre politique actuelle et qui ne va pas exister pendant la campagne présidentielle si elle est pas là.
Donc les Verts, s'ils étaient un tout petit peu intelligents, moi, je pense que vraiment, ils créeraient cette dynamique-là et ils diraient : « On la laisse y aller, on se range, on est d'accord, c'est ces combats-là qui sont importants.
» Et là, on aurait une petite chance. Là, mon espoir qu'on puisse le faire, parce que le seul espoir, et je suis pas sûre que ça marche, c'est qu'on passe au premier tour dès dimanche.
Ce que personne ne croit à ça. Moi, je sais pas. Je pense qu'on a, voilà, on verra.
Et ce sera dimanche, c'est ça ?
Ouais, c'est dimanche.
OK, ben on verra. On va peut-être refermer cette parenthèse—
Oui, pardon.
Non, mais y a pas de souci.
Je suis en train tout le jour là-dessus, évidemment.
C'était la question, y a pas de souci. Mais donc cette parenthèse politique française. Si maintenant, je reviens sur la question du militantisme.
Ouais.
Ce que tu dis parfois quand tu t'adresses aux militantes féministes, c'est : « Soyez courageuses, devenez lesbiennes. »
Je pense que tout le monde ne comprend pas cette phrase. Est-ce que tu peux l'expliquer ?
C'est sois exigeante, je crois, devenez lesbienne.
Ouais, soyez exigeante, ouais.
Ouais, c'était un peu, c'était une boutade, mais à la fois, je pense. C'est-à-dire que c'était une phrase, on m'a demandé en fait, c'est National Geographic, c'est voilà, une enquête sur les féministes.
Alors, ils interviewaient aussi bien, je sais pas, Melinda Gates que moi, que d'autres gens. Enfin voilà, plein de gens très différents, au niveau de notoriété très différents.
Et puis ils disent : « Qu'est-ce que vous donneriez comme conseil à une jeune fille de 20 ans ? » Et moi, c'est juste parce que j'ai réfléchi en fait à qu'est-ce que j'aurais aimé qu'on me donne comme conseil à 20 ans.
Et j'aurais aimé qu'on me dise ça, en fait, parce que ça m'aurait fait gagner
beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup d'années. Et je crois que ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut ne pas s'offrir la possibilité d'être lesbienne, donc déjà leur faire connaître qu'il y a cette possibilité-là, et puis ne pas l'avoir en tête.
C'est dommage, en fait, parce que rien que de l'avoir en tête, je pense que ça aide à davantage formuler, y compris si on reste dans des relations hétéros.
Ça aide de savoir que cette possibilité-là, elle existe et puis elle fonctionne bien pour beaucoup de femmes. Je pense que ça ouvre un peu le champ des possibles, quelle que soit la relation.
Et aussi parce que pour moi, lesbienne, vraiment, c'est pas une question de, c'est vraiment pas une question de sexualité, en fait.
C'est vraiment pas une question d'orientation sexuelle. Et que ça, je pense que c'est encore, quand je parlais des champs d'activité,
humaines qui ne sont que le reflet d'un conditionnement lié à la domination masculine, la sexualité en est un par excellence, auquel j'arrive même pas à...
Moi, ça, je suis pas encore là pour le, j'arrive pas à comprendre tout ça. C'est-à-dire que je pense que c'est tellement miné, la sexualité comme champ, ça a tellement été occupé essentiellement par une parole et par des images
masculines que c'est très, très, très dur à comprendre.
En tout cas, ce dont je suis sûre, c'est que ça, c'est pas aussi omniprésent qu'on... C'est pas comme ça, en fait.
La sexualité n'est pas aussi omniprésente, ne devrait pas, en tout cas, être aussi omniprésente dans les définitions de rapports de couple.
C'est même une absurdité. Donc quand on m'explique, parce que souvent, ce qu'on me rétorque, c'est : « Bah oui, mais bon, vous allez pas les obliger.
Si elles ont pas de désir, elles ont pas de désir. Ah mais moi, d'accord, je voudrais bien être lesbienne, mais,
mais j'ai pas de... » Je crois que c'est un problème complètement faux, cette question du désir, puisque très souvent, celles-là mêmes qui peuvent me dire ça vont me dire aussi : « Mais non, mais ça fait, je sais pas, un an,
non, je couche plus tellement
avec mon mec » ou...
Enfin, la sexualité n'est pas centrale non plus dans des, ou pas de cette manière-là, en tout cas. C'est pas possible de définir ça comme ça, je trouve.
C'est, ou alors c'est, enfin, pour moi, il y a quelque chose d'un peu absurde quoi, si c'est, dans un, si le désir sexuel se résume vraiment à, enfin en tout cas, si la,
ouais, voilà, si l'orientation sexuelle est capable de nous définir sur comment on choisit notre vie, c'est quand même... Je trouve ça très compliqué en fait.
En tout cas, moi, ça s'applique absolument pas à moi. Je veux dire, c'est pas du tout un problème. Je suis pas du tout lesbienne parce que je désire sexuellement des femmes.
Mmh.
Ça n'a rien à voir ou parce que je ne désire pas sexuellement des hommes. Ce qui est pas spécialement le cas d'ailleurs.
Enfin, je veux dire, y a pas... donc c'est pas du tout une question de désir, c'est vraiment une question de positionnement par rapport aux hommes.
Ça n'a aucunement facilité ton entrée dans les communautés lesbiennes d'être directement attirée par les femmes ? Ça n'a vraiment aucun rapport, t'es sûre de ça ?
Bah, je pense c'est plutôt l'inverse hein. C'est plutôt, enfin, je pense que le désir est quand même éminemment construit.
C'est quelque chose de pas... 'Fin, je pense même tout ce qu... et encore une fois, tout ce qu'on met, s'il fallait pousser un peu, les figures sexuelles aussi sont très construites.
Je sais pas moi, de la fellation ou cunnilingus, c'est quand même des trucs, y a un abécédaire quand même extrêmement construit de la sexualité qui n'est pas en soi,
donc qui plaque en fait certains imaginaires, certains que je ne crois pas.
On est directement dans nos corps et nos imaginaires d'êtres humains comme ça. C'est extrêmement construit, hein, je crois quand même, ces choses-là.
Et en plus, enfin dans la phrase, moi, j'expliquais : soyez exigeantes, devenez lesbiennes ou au moins apprenez à vous passer du regard des hommes.
Mmh.
En fait, c'est ça. Ce que je veux dire, c'est que pour moi, être lesbienne, c'est d'abord échapper, oui, au regard des hommes dans des choses de, des questions, OK, de séduction, de désir, mais bien plus largement en fait,
dans les entraves en fait psychiques que ça peut produire d'être sans arrêt dans un monde qui est d'abord regardé puis dit par les hommes.
C'est surtout ça, auquel moi j'essaye d'échapper et qui, je pense, quand même libère un peu la psyché.
Dans le livre, ce que tu expliques, c'est que les combats sociaux les plus
importants, les plus médiatisés, que ce soit même la question de l'avortement, Black Lives Matter, les manifestations contre les armes à feu, le mariage pour tous en Irlande.
Tous ces combats-là, au front, on trouvait des femmes lesbiennes.
Mmh.
Et tu expliques que les lesbiennes sont les meilleures, les plus grandes militantes du monde. Qu'est-ce qui...
Pourquoi ? Alors c'est un constat d'abord que moi j'avais pas,
j'avais pas fait attention parce qu'on me disait jamais que c'était des lesbiennes, on me disait jamais ça, mais que effectivement, quand je me suis intéressée à beaucoup
de différentes luttes, je me suis dit : « Tiens, y a quand même très très très
souvent des lesbiennes qui étaient à la coordination de ces luttes-là ».
Et ça, c'est pas une essence, c'est pas « Tiens, tiens, je suis lesbienne, donc je suis géniale ».
C'est pas ça. C'est parce que y a,
ça forge en fait un certain caractère et certaines facultés. Il faut, vu l'état actuel de la société et vu l'état actuel des rapports de force entre norme
hétérosexuelle, hétéropatriarcale et possibilité d'être lesbienne, arriver au stade où vous êtes capable de comprendre ça, d'assumer le fait d'être lesbienne,
de le dire publiquement, de vous vivre en tant que lesbienne dans des luttes.
Ça demande de développer des facultés qui sont
très semblables à celles dont on a besoin
dans de nombreuses luttes. C'est-à-dire, en gros,
ne pas avoir peur, ne pas avoir peur de gueuler contre les, 'fin de s'opposer à un pouvoir qui est souvent un pouvoir masculin, comprendre ce qui se joue parce que c'est des structures de domination.
Elles ressortent aussi souvent, elles peuvent avoir leurs particularités, mais les structures de domination coloniales, patriarcales, y a des points communs très forts. Donc comprendre,
sur des luttes environnementales aussi.
Donc l'avoir compris, l'avoir fait dans votre propre parcours, la force qu'il faut pour faire ça, pour en arriver là, parce que ça pèse quand même encore beaucoup sur le... 'fin c'est pas simple encore d'y arriver, à dire de pas avoir peur.
Eh ben ça, ça vous donne, c'est une bonne école en fait après, pour faire du militantisme. Donc je pense que c'est ce qui explique aussi qu'on retrouve de nombreuses lesbiennes dans,
dans les luttes et les illustrations que je vois, c'est-à-dire que c'est pas du tout anodin pour moi que par exemple, Adèle Haenel,
soit celle qui a fait exploser le MeToo dans le cinéma français, qu'on a attendu un bout de temps hein quand même,
et qu'elle soit lesbienne.
C'est pas un hasard, voilà. Et c'est pas parce que A, elle est lesbienne, elle a des super pouvoirs, même si elle a aussi des super pouvoirs, Adèle.
Mais c'est pas seulement ça. C'est parce que,
pour s'affirmer comme telle dans un milieu, alors qui est quand même une quintessence hein, le cinéma, en termes de, ça se pose là hein, les représentations du cinéma en termes d'assignation de genre,
d'assignation de rapports entre hommes et femmes, etc.
D'être capable de dire ça, ça vient complètement briser justement tout cet imaginaire, tous ces codes-là. Donc déjà un travail a été fait auparavant
qui après fait que vous êtes capable de réagir et de percevoir davantage ce qui est en train de se jouer, quand on remet un César à quelqu'un comme Roman Polanski.
Mmh.
Donc c'est, y a un passé aussi derrière.
Courage politique face...
Voilà
...à des institutions masculines bien en place, une indépendance d'esprit puisque on échappe, le génie lesbien, on échappe au regard et au jugement masculin.
C'est plus simple, ça repose beaucoup en fait hein d'échapper au regard. Du coup, y a une énergie psychique, je pense, et une énergie tout court en plus.
Ça, je pense. On perd beaucoup moins de...
C'est fatigant hein quand même de lutter contre la masculinité. Donc quand vous l'avez pas aussi à vous poser trop de questions dans votre foyer, ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas d'autres soucis hein, je veux dire, mais c'est,
ça repose aussi, ouais.
Mmh, mmh, mmh. Mmh. Alors, on arrive au point Wittig du podcast où on va commencer à citer Monique Wittig et la pensée straight.
Alors c'est toi la spécialiste. J'espère que je ne vais pas déformer son propos. Mais ce qu'elle fait grosso modo dans la pensée straight, c'est remettre en question
ce qu'elle appelle le régime de l'hétérosexualité en tant que doctrine politique.
Elle dit qu'on évolue dans un monde où on est inévitablement essentialisé en tant qu'homme, en tant que femme, donc en tant que dominé ou dominant.
Et donc finalement, elle arrive à la conclusion de dire : « Et donc les lesbiennes qui échappent donc au regard, au jugement des hommes, ne sont pas des femmes ».
Mmh.
Alors, est-ce que tu es une femme, Alice ?
Moi, ouais, je revendique beaucoup le, en fait le... Le terme, ce terme-là, je pense, mais pour des raisons intrinsèquement de combat politique.
Mh. Mh. Tu es assignée femme...
Voilà, je pense que...
Tu es perçue comme femme dans l'espace social.
Ouais, enfin ça, mais ça a pas été très... C'est-à-dire, très longtemps, ça n'a rien voulu dire. C'est-à-dire que c'est quand j'ai compris le mot en tant que catégorie politique...
Mh.
Mais ce qui est aussi ce que veut dire Wittig dans ça et en ce sens-là, que les lesbiennes échappent à la catégorie politique femme.
Or moi, la catégorie politique femme, elle m'intéresse, au sens où, bah j'ai envie de l'aider, de la défendre. Mais...
La sororité, finalement.
Ouais. Et voilà, enfin en tout cas, et de comprendre ça comme une catégorie politique. Et c'est seulement à partir de là que j'ai pu assumer pleinement d'être une femme.
Mais avant, c'était quelque chose d'extrêmement compliqué pour moi, l'appartenance à la féminité, l'appartenance à la catégorie femme.
Mais depuis, je, précisément, bah que je suis militante féministe, en fait, ça m'aide énormément à pouvoir me situer en tant qu'appartenant au corps des femmes.
Oui, oui. Ce qu'elle dit aussi, et là, tu me diras ce que t'en penses, mais je trouve qu'on touche presque à une forme d'universalisme, c'est qu'il faudrait, selon elle,
remettre en question cette dichotomie les hommes, les femmes, et non, non, non, non pas faire l'un et l'autre, mais plutôt juste un tout.
Mh.
Et elle dit aussi : « Pour nous, les lesbiennes, il existe non pas un ou deux sexes, mais autant de sexes qu'il y a d'individus ».
Est-ce que tu adhères à ça aussi ? Parce que tu parles beaucoup dans ton livre des hommes et des femmes.
Oui alors, bah, oui. Alors après, c'est toujours, parce que j'explique aussi que par ailleurs,
en tant que lesbienne sans cesse mégenrée, les problématiques de non binarité, des problématiques encore très différentes qui sont celles de transidentité,
en tant notamment que lesbienne, plutôt butch, me sont extrêmement proches. Enfin...
Mh.
C'est vraiment des combats qui me... Y a beaucoup de choses très similaires avec la spécificité des combats contre la transphobie, la spécificité des combats sur la non binarité.
Mais c'est quelque chose quand même,
qu'on expérimente beaucoup, par exemple, le fait d'être mégenré systématiquement et donc de trouver qu'il y a une absurdité, évidemment, des genres sociaux, d'hommes et de femmes, puisqu'ils sont...
vous êtes même pas capables de reconnaître.
Moi, on passe ma vie à m'appeler monsieur, donc arrêtez.
Artificiel, c'est construit, c'est...
Pourquoi vous voulez, si vous êtes même pas foutus de le savoir. Vous avez inventé des codes, vous savez pas vous-même...
C'est ça
...vous y repérer, donc c'est une plaisanterie. Après, c'est encore une fois, c'est différent, les,
ces assignations sociales là, que l'utilité qu'il peut y avoir à quand même brandir des combats, justement, au nom du féminisme,
au nom des femmes, ce que je trouve toujours très important à faire en fait.
Oui. Elle va même jusqu'à expliquer que selon elle, les femmes ne devraient pas être fières d'être femmes parce que ça revient à être fières d'être dominées.
Est-ce que tu la rejoins là-dessus aussi ou pas ?
Encore une fois, je pense que c'est, dans ce...
Oui, il faut toujours remettre les choses dans le contexte.
Oui, bien sûr.
Voilà.
J'adhère complètement au texte de Wittig. Ça veut pas dire que transposé dans un autre langage politique de 2021, on ne puisse pas revendiquer.
Bon moi, j'ai pas spécialement, oui, non, de fierté, enfin le langage de la fierté, par ailleurs, n'est pas spécialement...
D'accord
...le mien en politique ou dans des choses comme ça. Et c'est vraiment, oui, c'est vrai.
En revanche, je crois vraiment toujours valable, c'est-à-dire que,
pff, d'ailleurs, je suis pas super à l'aise pour répondre aux questions sur les catégories femmes, parce que moi, je viens vraiment d'une matrice qui est la barbe, qui est précisément de dire
: « Non mais les femmes, là, nous, on va pas trop s'en occuper.
En fait, occupons-nous des hommes.
Mh.
Occupons-nous de, justement, allons, braquons l'éclairage sur justement, et on pourrait ajouter les hommes cis, hétéros.
On pourrait ajouter un certain nombre de qualificatifs. Occupons-nous des hommes. C'est ça qui m'intéresse d'abord quoi, d'aller déminer.
Et c'est parce que je pense que s'occuper des questions de domination masculine, c'est s'occuper encore une fois de l'ensemble du fonctionnement de la société.
C'est pour ça que ça m'intéresse autant.
Mh. Alors, on approche tout doucement de la fin de cet entretien. Si on parle maintenant du futur, des évolutions qu'on voit, ces temps-ci.
Voilà, je pense que les choses ont énormément évolué déjà ces 10 dernières années, ces 20 dernières années.
Mh.
Comment est-ce que tu vois les choses dans un futur proche, dans un futur lointain ? Est-ce que tu penses que avant ta mort, on aura vu des évolutions systémiques importantes ?
Alors déjà, je pense qu'il faut faire attention aux formulations. En fait, les choses, elles ont pas évolué. C'est disons que les combats se sont...
Voilà.
bien organisés, ces dernières années, qu'on est plutôt, en tout cas sur la dernière décennie, mettons, dans une...
avec des combats qui sont extrêmement intéressants, dans le renouvellement de leur forme, parce que c'est toujours, ils sont pas nouveaux hein, ces combats-là.
Et ça fait des décennies et des décennies qu'il y a des féministes ou des lesbiennes ou d'autres personnes absolument géniales qui se battent.
Mais c'est vrai que je trouve que ce qui se passe en ce moment est particulièrement intéressant, effectivement, depuis quelques années.
Après, la question, c'était celle de est-ce qu'un jour, tout ça, ça va... Et c'est compliqué parce que vraiment, le souci, c'est je crois vraiment que c'est tel... on vit, on respire tellement cet air-là, en fait.
Je crois qu'on n'est pas au début seul... 'fin, on n'arrive même pas encore au tout début de la compréhension d'à quel point le patriarcat a infusé chaque petit pan de notre vie quotidienne.
Et du coup, bien sûr, y a des, il y a des, 'fin, le voir en terme de progrès même ou d'historicité, je pense est compliqué en fait, parce que c'est une matrice quoi le patriarcat.
Donc c'est partout. Donc c'est pas une question seulement de tiens, ça va mieux, tiens, avant elles étaient que une, maintenant, elles sont dix à cet endroit-là.
Oui, ça on pourra y arriver, je pense. Ça, c'est vrai. Ça va changer numériquement parce que on a fait passer des lois, que ça soit des lois sur la parité comme ça,
parce que on arrive dans des combats à faire une énorme, à mettre une énorme pression en fait,
et à faire que certains comprennent que en fait c'est plus acceptable maintenant d'avoir que des hommes partout.
Mais le fondement du fondement du fondement, là, il change pas. Moi, je pense que ça bouge pas d'un iota là en fait hein.
Et pour le changement de... c'est vraiment, là c'est autre chose qui se joue, qui est bien, bien, bien plus profond et qui là ne fonctionnera pas sans,
je sais pas en fait comment ça va exactement se terminer.
Mais ce qui est sûr, c'est que ça prendra longtemps, longtemps, longtemps et que c'est un travail presque de révolution des inconscients humains.
Enfin donc c'est, ça va chercher extrêmement loin quoi.
On arrive au bout de Septante Minutes. Une dernière question peut-être, tu es aujourd'hui à Bruxelles.
Ouais.
On a beaucoup parlé de la France jusqu'à présent.
Est-ce que tu as un regard de, un regard français, un regard situé parisien vers la Belgique ? Qu'est-ce que tu penses des situations en ce qui concerne, voilà, le lesbianisme politique ?
On parlait de l'invisibilisation du mot lesbien, etc.
Ouais.
En Belgique, est-ce que les choses te paraissent différentes, meilleures, pires ? Est-ce que tu as un avis sur ces questions ?
Alors moi, pour moi, vous avez une des meilleures lesbiennes au monde qui est la présidente de la Conférence européenne lesbienne qui s'appelle Joëlle Sambi Nzeba, qui,
qui sort un livre d'ailleurs qui s'appelle Caillasses récemment, qui est une lesbienne congo-belge et qui est absolument, qui incarne tout ce qu'est le génie lesbien.
Donc déjà, vous avez de la chance dans votre ville de l'avoir. Mais aussi plein d'autres, 'fin moi, j'aime beaucoup, 'fin y a quand même une scène lesbienne qui me plaît beaucoup à Bruxelles.
Il va y avoir, et d'ailleurs, l'ALC va organiser une Lesbiennale, là, en octobre, qui est la contraction de lesbienne et biennale, jeu de mots, et qui, voilà, ça sera là.
Et moi, je trouve que c'est, c'est, moi, j'ai aimé, je suis venue beaucoup à Bruxelles et j'ai aimé être lesbienne à Bruxelles, je dois avouer.
Donc ouais, c'était, voilà. Mais après, non, après, c'est compliqué parce qu'en fait, je vous dis ça parce qu'en plus, nous, notre figure tout à l'heure,
c'était très gentil de me dire que j'étais la lesbienne la plus connue
en France, mais je crois vraiment que la lesbienne la plus connue en France, enfin, en tout cas, je sais pas si elle, mais pour les lesbiennes, la figure importante, elle est, et pour les jeunes aussi,
elle est belge et c'est Angèle.
Donc vous voyez, même nous, on prend vos modèles, on n'est même pas capables de vous avoir.
Mais on parlait d'invisibilisation et je dois, je t'avoue que je n'étais même pas au courant qu'Adèle Haenel était lesbienne avant de lire ton livre. Et—
Angèle, oui.
Angèle, oui, mais, mais Angèle—
Je crois qu'elle se, je sais pas si elle...
Dans mon esprit, je pensais qu'elle était bi, mais peut-être lesbienne aussi dans le sens plus politique que tu lui prêtes.
Mais ça, je ne la connais pas assez. Je lui poserai la question.
En tout cas, elle a en elle du génie lesbien.
Mais voilà, formidable. Formidable conclusion. Merci beaucoup Alice. Et on se retrouve alors dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode.
Merci.
Au revoir.
Et voilà, c'est ici que s'achève mon entretien de Septante Minutes Avec Alice Coffin. Quelques précisions par rapport à ce qui a été dit.
On discute à un moment de la primaire écologiste française. On a enregistré cet épisode moins d'une semaine avant les résultats du premier tour.
Et comme Alice l'espérait, Sandrine Rousseau s'est effectivement qualifiée pour le second tour. J'espère que vous avez apprécié cette interview.
Ce podcast n'est pas sur Patreon. Il est gratuit, sans pub, sans placement de produit. La seule chose que je vous demande, si vous avez aimé, c'est d'en parler autour de vous.
Ça aide à faire grandir le podcast. Ça m'aide à booker des invités qui, avant, étaient peut-être hors de portée pour moi.
Donc, s'il vous plaît, faites-le. Et si ce n'est pas encore fait, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée et sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tous les liens sont dans la description. Dans deux semaines, je recevrai Ron Lomas pour parler de ses travaux de recherche sur la prostitution en Belgique et dans le reste du monde.
Je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut salut !